foreign
these small QR codes accompanied our
travel since the second year of the
coronavirus pandemic consisting of
intricate black and white squares
scanned by digital devices they are the
core of the digital covered certificate
launched by the European Union one year
ago helping citizens travel across
borders again
[Music]
globally more than 1.8 billion
certificates have been issued in digital
or paper format so far
67 countries have joined that system 27
EU member states three from the European
economic area and 37 Nations outside of
Europe
[Music]
the phase of the creation the World
Health Organization was one of the
partners who joined forces with Europe
to select the technical specifications
to register and validate once
vaccination status
soon the need for interoperable and
standard-based recording and recognition
of vaccination status against covid-19
for domestic and cross-border purposes
has been identified European covet
certificate initiative is responding to
that particular need
interoperability is a key function in
order to build a system connecting
dozens of countries to make this
possible the commission set up a digital
Gateway making National I.T systems and
allowing seamless verification of the QR
codes
the covert certificate came into effect
on July 1 2021 to enable free movement
within the EU during the pandemic the QR
code contains key information such as
name date of birth date of issue
vaccination and Recovery dates as well
as test records
the personal data remains on the
certificate and is not stored at any
level
the pandemic has definitely shown that
cross-border Access to Health Data is
key in the response to health
emergencies
the successful experience of the digital
code certificate created in only three
months has been the result of a joint
effort and a pragmatic approach
we managed to keep complexity at the
minimum that was difficult to fit
everything what was needed in this very
small QR code and at the same time to
ensure the security of the system and
the possibility to verify the contents
without using any online services for
that and that was made possible because
of a very smart way of packing that
information and encoding and digital
assigning it
in the coming few years the whole power
of digital Health tools will be
expressed by the European health data
space
the initiative presented by the European
Commission in May 2022 will support
National Health policies research and
the quality of healthcare thanks to the
cross-border exchange of Health Data
can really
enable us to address many challenges
together and these are all challenges
that we face when putting forward the EU
digital certificate and now that has
opened up further innovation in the EU
in the area of digital Health Solutions
similar to the digital covet certificate
may be implemented in other ways in the
future According to some health sector
experts QR codes could be used to check
information on other vaccinations or
even to share other data with health
professionals at the click of a button
foreign
[Music]